only fans would you recommend authors  how much money do you think you and I  can make if we didn't like bathtub  scenes in only fans not just chilling  just reading like reading like Animal  Farm just like while sitting in reality  I don't know okay snowflake  snowfall sorry snowball okay snowball  uh all right what was his name no the  horse  I I will work harder  now that guy I think about that guy a  lot boxer yeah he's uh his model was I  will work harder anything that happens  like the the the pigs would take  advantage and his response to everything  he was inspiring to me because he never  gave in to the cynicism right and they  killed him yeah spoiler sorry  but that's a good way to die never  giving in  well yeah there's a lot of that in this  book about the people who were like I'm  not you're not gonna break me like I'm  bigger than this